Here he comes, boys!
Prepare yourselves!
(Growling, screaming)
♪♪
Who hath summoned me
to this realm?!
Dude!
You summoned Satan!
Yeah no doi!
What'dya think we were doing?!
Prince of darkness!
It is I, Al Gore!
I was almost
president!
What do you wish of me,
Al Gore?!
A demon from Hell
has been unleashed
upon our world!
We demand
to know its nature!
We demand to know
its reason for coming!
There is only one place you can
find the answers you seek!
It is the place
where all knowledge
becomes known!
Your local library.
Ah! You are
correct.
Your local library
is an excellent resource
for whatever
you wish to learn.
Yes, it is.
Then I command
thee, Satan,
to come with us
to the local library!
And I am cereal!
Dude, Satan's not gonna
go with us to the --
Very well, Al Gore.
Let us go!